las víctimas del exilio quieren ser
reconocidas desde suiza hasta bogotá un
puñado de los colombianos exiliados
contaron sus historias y aunque cada uno
padeció a diferentes grupos armados
tienen algo en común porque qué pasó
antes y obviamente hay muchas respuestas
distintas porque cada quien tuvo que
salir
pero también hay una corrección a muchas
por pensar diferente
en colombia ese costo no solo lo pagaron
sindicalistas líderes indígenas y
políticos de izquierda las amenazas
también llevaron al exilio a miembros de
la fuerza pública y de la rama judicial
hoy sus casos siguen en la impunidad es
triste decirlo pero
no hubo justicia para quienes
administramos justicia
entre 2017 y 2019 cerca de 500.000
colombianos se exiliaron en países como
venezuela costa rica españa o canadá y
muchos dicen sentirse en el limbo ya sea
porque los rechazan al volver a colombia
o porque empiezan de cero en el país que
los acoge con una lengua que no es la
suya
me convertí
en una y letrada peor que una y letrada
porque un letrado puede comunicar cuando
desea
el medio de los casi nueve millones de
víctimas del conflicto los exiliados
colombianos quedaron relegados hasta el
punto que no aparecen en los registros
oficiales de víctimas y ahora la
comisión de la verdad quiere visibilizar
sus relatos esta comisión de la verdad
es no digo la primera pero es la
comisión de la verdad en el mundo que
más cuidado le ha puesto al exilio
además de recuperar su voz estas
víctimas quieren saber la verdad
estructural sobre quién los presionó
hasta el exilio más allá de conocer la
identidad del sicario que atentó contra
sus vidas